[Musik]
taxi weil wichtige mann der stunde
jetzt weiß ich wie ich mit anderen mit
manchen muss ungar
ich weiß wie autoritätspersonen wie ich
das torlose oder oder deine folge was
sie sagen was für eine junge zog sie ist
aber jetzt mittlerweile habe ich das
klein ich habe gelernt mit geld und gar
nicht nur das große geld so wie ich für
japan also steelbooks hat mich sehr viel
kohle vom lager wo ich mit bin ein
besserer mensch wurde ja definitiv
was ist das für ein mensch der immer
wieder aufsteht egal wie habt ihr das
leben trifft
davon handelt dieser film
meine stärken will und bin mein glaube
habe mich selber und setzte was ich
meine gedanken oder so was ich mir
folgenden sätze ich hatte wurde
[Applaus]
dominik sauff setzte sich nie mit taktik
und technik durch sondern immer mit co2
und gewalt das gilt sowohl für seine
über 100 kämpfe als profisportler was
auch für seine karriere als krimineller
[Applaus]
bevor er nach thailand ging und
kampfsportler wurde was sie doof ein
sogenannter intensivtäter einbrüche
raubüberfälle vielen prügeln die meisten
seiner delikte konnten ihm allerdings
nicht zugeordnet werden er war clever
genug sich beizeiten ins ausland
abzusetzen um dort in aller ruhe die
verjährung abzuwarten
die glücklichste mannschaft der welt wie
gut sind sie dann zurück
asian small ich bin zum freien mann
keine vorstrafen
ich habe ihn macht finde ich habe meine
existenz aufbaute ein kosmopolit kann
endlich wieder respektiert werden
das team unterstützt mit trainer
respektiert
ich glaube auch dass mehr personen
was hat man aber stets auf den themen
oder schlecht blieb man immer noch nicht
aber er ist ein gentleman schlitz
die geschichte dieses gentleman
schlitzohrs ist ein schönes beispiel
dafür wie frei der mensch ist auf seinem
anlagen zu machen was er will dass er
kein opfer von reits mussten in seinem
gehirn lässt dass es sich zum beispiel
dafür entscheiden kann kriminell zu sein
oder es auch lassen kann
[Musik]
in thailand war zieht auf zwar weit weg
vom rat der schweizer justiz aber auch
gefangen in perspektivlosigkeit seine
einzige option war sich für geld zu
prügeln
er fing an sechs stunden pro tag zu
trainieren buchstäblich bis zum
erbrechen provinz stadien ließ er sich
für ein paar franken den kopf
einschlagen
da begann im zu themen dass sein leben
nur eine richtung kannte abwärts
[Musik]
ich danke wie jeder mensch muss es sehr
schnell weg bis man im griff behalte ich
länger wieder andere geschütze wie mir
das ziemlich langweilig behalten rebecca
mir weil auf andere lose ich habe mein
ich bin der chef ich bin gut drauf der
wahl das geht nur mich und der rest
nicht mehr egal und das technische bild
ganz anders
ich nehme mit manchen war kümmere mich
um ihn mit mancher ein steinschlag gott
wenn sich meine kollegen schlag kommt
zum iran schlacht und das ist einfach
für internet nutzen
was sagen kreativ solche frühere profi
ich habe für ein kalkül
also ich kann natürlich meine familie
und so aber eigentlich umwelt und mich
umarmt ist mir scheißegal sind können
wir sterben und ich glaube dass sie und
ich weiterlaufen
[Musik]
sid office dauernd unterwegs ständig
unter leuten als oberes mit dem blick
nach innen nicht übertreiben und dem
nahkampf mit sich selber lieber aus dem
weg gehen wollte
[Musik]
ich glaube ich bin der gerne gefallen
ist ich bin freundlich viele lexikon sie
zum baugrund jetzt die stadt tobt
die kurze heimreise stunden 2 und
überlegt und dann noch die wände kein
politikum
[Musik]
sich aufs mutter konnte nicht flüchten
sie musste bleiben in der agglomeration
der stadt zürich wohin sie in den
siebziger jahren mit ihrem mann aus ex
jugoslawien gekommen war um hart zu
arbeiten damit es ihre kinder einmal
besser hätte das dominik so wenig aus
seinen chancen machte und es ihm egal
war dass seine familie seinetwegen zum
großen tuschel thema im dorf wurde hat
seine mutter bis heute nicht verwunden
[Musik]
ich bin zu ihm standen gut und das ist
gut so billig die hände aber ich bin
jetzt einfach so ich verdanke ich den
pinnower wegstoßen oder das ist das gab
mir sie hat nur dass ich mein kind immer
noch und weber und bedroht so ich will
wissen sie doch alle paar jahre mal in
die schweiz kommt mischen sich freude
und die angst auch die wunden wieder
aufzureißen
ich habe gewusst was ich muss machen
dass sie keinen verdacht schöpft oder so
vor dem herrn schon gute spieler dazu
haben wir die rückspiegel tatsächlich
merkt dass nicht alles sagen das habe
ich schon gemerkt vielleicht nicht dir
das mal was ich wirklich so
versteckspiel laxey wo man geht jetzt
aus nachhinein bin ich froh dass ich das
mein größter wunsch hat sie doch einfach
sagen und seine lehre als automechaniker
schmiss er nach nur einem jahr hin
erfolg hatte er aus krimineller stoff
ist ein alphatier er kann menschen
führen
er brachte es innert kürzester zeit zum
boss einer straßengang und er ist eitel
seine lebensgeschichte findet er so
interessant dass sie sich auf die haut
tätowieren und ständig aktualisieren
lässt
ich war schon immer wieder anders sie
als andere runde will ich nicht gern
mich augenlider ein normaler also
wirklich aussieht dass sie ich würde das
mit zum muster sieht da sage ich möchte
einfach im rücken speziell sie sehen
sich speziell ja es gibt sicher ich sage
ja soll ich sagen ich finde ich mich
speziell was ist ein spezieller fehlers
vieles und natürlich der vw ließ ich mir
das jetzt
natürlich ist wo sind sie speziell an
starker wille ist sehr speziell
was ich mir den kopf setzen dass wir
dadurch zogen egal wie egal was das ich
sehr spezieller mehr
diese käme seiner persönlichkeit den man
auch rücksichtslosigkeit nennen könnte
hat sich nicht verändert sie doch hat
sich nur legale betätigungsfelder
gesucht im gegensatz zu früher
bei mir alles an weil er bewiesen der
maxi sind haben wir müssen total sie und
man natürlich die in der disco beats und
die andere gruppe ist an der ecke von
der disco und doch sehr stolz und du
läufst du deine vw heißen asche papillon
die an sich ist ausgeschlossen
der murano struck nicht alles grün und
blau das innere spaltung in diesem jahr
steht sie also sind mein leben und ich
war manchmal muss gold bekommt jetzt
mittlerweile ziemlich selbstsicher ich
finde das tun aber du musst sie strahlt
zutage weil die studie
also ich einfach also unsere etwa
tischtennis oder so sie aber immer und
der mannschaft doch dann sauber sowie
genau genommen dass also der mannschaft
war und ich war halt nur tropfen ich bin
hier und will ich mich vielleicht weil
es das thema passen
diese revolution die aus profitieren der
nachbar gewesen war gibt es zu sehen
sind tragische mit 22 hatte sie doch
gerade eine haftstrafe wegen der
verbreitung von falschgeld abgesessen
und war schon wieder mit einem bein im
knast
denn es war nur eine frage der zeit bis
man im weitere delikte hätte zuordnen
können
er musste weg und zwar schnell
[Musik]
die paradiesische kulisse täuscht und
thailand als ausländer geld zu verdienen
ist harte arbeit tag für tag nur schon
seine monatlichen fixkosten von 600
franken zu decken ist für zieht auf eine
herausforderung für migration mit dem
thai boxer verdienst du halt immer noch
nicht nur geil zum in europa habe also
und in thailand landes da bleibt viel
geld im monat und von der acs-gruppe
faktor und die der schweiz im jahr heute
nicht so gut ich schob sich das an der
krems bildung und ausbildung
der strafakt galt falsche und ich glaube
dass sie keine arbeitgeber gerne und da
interessiert das nicht danach aber und
zwar noch nie im bevölkert salon jemand
fragt sag ich an dich domini
vergangenheit gern der litt unter
massiver aber wenn sie bis davor waren
müsste ich verheimliche will ich hoffe
aber dass räder und vor einem jahr noch
nicht mit einem kuss problem sieht oft
von der hand in den mund rücklagen hat
er praktisch keine dafür ein
unerschütterliches selbstbewusstsein
hart an der grenze zur
realitätsverweigerung
zukunftsland habe ich dann khalid wird
so kommt sagen scheint sehr glücklich im
lamer und sie sind glücklich
vor sechs jahren hat sie doch kurz vor
dem großen durchbruch
der zufall spielte ihn in eine
asiatische reality show mit dem titel
der contender eine art big brother für
thai boxer 16 kandidaten kämpften so
lange gegeneinander bis nur noch einer
stand
[Musik]
der kampf hat mich hat bekommt macht von
der novelle musiker und immer wieder
vorwirft stunde beim niederschlag hat
nicht nur sauber dankte der bringt aber
irgendwie ich bin einfach so mal
schiefgehen kassel
[Musik]
sich einfach nicht von 23 sekunden
später widerruft standen mittags stoff
hatte keine chance auf den sieg auf sein
kämpferherz machte ihn zum heimlichen
star der show plötzlich wurde er auf der
straße abkommt und schrieb autogramme
sein traum schien in greifbarer nähe
reich zu werden ganz legal
mittlerweile ist er zurück in der
realität
er wurde zwar bekannt ob das große geld
blieb eine illusion denn für nach ganz
oben für einen weltmeistertitel reichte
sein talent nicht und mit 32 steht er
nun bereits in der letzten runde seine
sportlerkarriere
ich wollte selber schreibe ich nenne
diese wählerische diese süßen und sind
bei der stube und in der küche aber wer
so ist dann kochen muss ja noch jährigen
und sie so ein koch hält kauf von tescos
und ganz einfach einfach wie möglich
man kann ihn als filmisches schon von
ihr getränk das board hughes ich
verbringe nicht viel zeit
die heime meistens nutzung schlafe ich
natürlich nicht fehlen das vermisst man
hat europa league ja das ist spitze
wenn man also auto wellness oase wo halt
die frage zieht mit braucht will ihr
eigenes vorschäden tag für mediziner
frau ihrem lover ganz ehrlich gesagt
moment nach belieben moment bin ich im
islam schmiede sozusagen also ich bin im
islam bilder also was ihre zukunft kommt
mir ist was viel wichtiger wäre jetzt zu
früh ins haus aber es sind junge mann
mit bedürfnisse aber in thailand ist es
schwierig für sie doch besteht das leben
nach chancen und erfolgen für ihn ist
klar das beste hat er noch vor sich auch
wenn er es bereits sehr weit gebracht
habe
kommt damit seine bisherigen höhepunkte
nicht vergessen gehen hat dass sie zu
einem 5 minütigen clip zusammenschneiden
lassen und teilt sie via youtube mit der
ganzen welt
[Musik]
die umwelt leisten wir ganz gewaltig
objektiv stimmte oder ganze welt kannst
von deinen vor dem landkreis bin im
moment hat schöne momente einem kampf
hat er indes verloren den um einen tag
der familie seine tochter lebt bei ihrer
mutter eine affäre aus der zeit als er
auf dem sprung nach ganz oben war
[Musik]
eigentlich immer nur neue mystery of the
world und schon in thailand klappt sie
in singapur und ich bin meine karriere
als boxer und biopsie und sie hat
mittlerweile nach thailand sicher nach
singapur und dann haben wir euch heute
so entschieden dass hier wird grant
geweiht worden
julia ist inzwischen fünf jahre alt und
ein gefragtes kindermodel sie verdient
an einem tag mehr und sie vater im
ganzen monat
ich habe kontakte tochter vorstellig
ich versuche so viel wie möglich
besuchen oder dass ich mich um kopftuch
oder was man sich trifft ich versuche
einen guten tag danke ich bin ein guter
vater will ich weiß was ich falsch
gemacht habe und ich versuche es besser
eine tochter mit
[Musik]
monika
zehn jahre kämpfte sie doch ohne
nennenswerte verletzungen und dann das
ein scooter unfall endete mit dem
verdacht auf kreuzbandriss
die luft muss pausieren sich vermutlich
operieren lassen und für ein paar monate
in die reha ist ein linkes knie schmerzt
sagt er aber wirklich weh tue es im kopf
ich immer das gefühl erinnern wenn du
wenn du es zu wie in der musik und den
ring die nervosität jahr sparen ist der
nervenkitzel und dann mann du über über
zeilen stieg schon zu tun
der kitzel der felten lange bevor
[Musik]
200 franken so viel bekommen diese
männer dafür dass sie ihre körper
kämpfen lassen nein die wahren sieger in
diesem sport sind nicht die die in den
ring steigen sondern jene die sie da
rein schicken um die touristen zu
unterhalten
[Applaus]
es ist heiße spur war das immer eine
kaum verteilt also ich weiß dass aber
die meisten dorf oder kaum verkaufen sie
verlauten und janni das nur die andere
top was ist aus dem off
ich bin ich bin mir dass wir bei unserem
wald wo ich bin und wo ich mich gerade
so verlieren ein kombinierter kommt von
den kunden
[Applaus]
es ist wenn sie ist durch meine frau und
ich bin glücklich und
okay von der vorteil jetzt raus und die
würden sagen wieso macht daraus aber
schlussendlich auch nicht muss der stoff
ist dazu da wo ich bin
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenn er nicht mehr fit werde keine ria
trainer werden sagt sie doch oder
promoter oder sonst was
einen kämpfer kennt man nicht daran wie
hat dazu schlagen kann sondern daran wie
viel er einstecken kann und ob er
trotzdem weitermacht
immer wieder niederschlag über aber es
kommt ja betroffen was du hast einen
niederschlag macht also sie weiter bis
nach ostern aber ich werde bis zum
schluss geblieben
[Musik]
das sollten sie nicht